>> Hi YouTube, this is Aysegul Ildeniz, the
Regional Director for Intel- in Africa. I
think role models are extremely important.
We are Intel try to role model particularly
in the area of education. What we are trying
to show to the rest of the world is every
kid deserves the opportunity to use a PC and
technology and they can do wonderful things
with it. This is why Intel is so dedicated
to incorporating PC into the education space
and this is why we have trained over 600,000
teachers in this region alone to make sure
they actually train those students the 21st
century skills and they become role models
for the students and their communities and
actually show that they are ahead of the game
just like in the rest of the world. They can
bring that goodness of technology and make
sure they educate our kids for the future
the right way.